in the White House Rose Garden in the
midst of a pandemic that's killed tens
of thousands the moment Donald Trump
decides his right to cut off the
millions America sends to the World
Health Organization a president who
accepts no blame himself keen to point
the finger today I'm instructing my
administration to halt
funding of the World Health Organization
while a review is conducted to assess
the World Health Organization's role in
severely mismanaging and covering up the
spread of the corona virus everybody
knows what's going on there the American
Medical Association called in a
dangerous move at a precarious moment
for the world the UN said now wasn't the
time for an inquest the w-h-o had
responded to the mere threat earlier
this week the states is actually the
largest contributor to whu-oh and what I
know is that is supportive and I hope
the funding to de Blasio will will
continue or Trump's more focused on it
seems is getting America open again but
backing down from his claim he had
ultimate authority to do it and
admitting it is up to governor's
in places like California where the
beaches would normally be packed in this
Spring Break holiday but we're an early
stay at home order seems to have paid
off a place with twice the population of
New York but a fraction of the deaths
the governor here is tentatively now
planning the reopening it will not be a
permanent state we recognize the
consequences of these stay at home
orders have a profound impact on the
economy your personal household budget
your personal prospects around your
future thank you all very much thank you
Donald Trump says he'll be watching the
states closely he's called the
coronavirus an invisible enemy but once
again he's shown he's more than willing
to pick a fight in its midst
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles